hier soir le dernier espoir que l'accord
puisse être ratifié a été anéantie quand
l'assemblée des jcc internet du labrador
ajourné centenaire de vote malgré une
entente unanime des provinces conclu
trois ans plutôt solide du lac meech
je tiens à saluer le travail remarquable
accompli aujourd'hui par tous les
premiers ministres l'accord
constitutionnel est mort il ya 25 ans
faute de ratification par le manitoba et
terre neuve un échec
traumatisant qui a provoqué un sursaut
nationaliste au québec puisque l'accord
visait à faire oublier le rapatriement
de la constitution canadienne en 1982
sans l'approbation de l'assemblée
nationale même le premier ministre
libéral robert bourassa s'il fait en
septembre le canada anglais voient
comprend une façon très claire que quoi
qu'on dise et quoi qu'on fasse
le québec est aujourd'hui et pour
toujours une société distincts libre et
capable d'assumer son destin et son
développement 25 ans plus tard mitch pas
toujours dans les mémoires de trouver un
printemps où on voit plus les
conséquences l'échec de meech que ce
printemps si où on ne parle que du sénat
de sa désuétude du débat entre les
partis le sénat a beau être minée par le
procès du sénateur mike duffy les
conclusions du vérificateur général sur
les dépenses excessives et les
allégations d'inconduite le réformer ou
l'abolir soulève le spectre d'une
nouvelle ronde constitutionnelle la cour
suprême a dit que si nous voulons abolir
le sénat il faut le consentement du
parlement et des assemblées de toutes
les provinces
une simple réforme plus modestes
pourraient échapper à la règle de
l'unanimité
si difficile à atteindre ça c'est une
modification constitutionnelle par la
procédure normale c'est-à-dire cette
province qui représente 50% de la
population canadienne est évidemment le
parlement fédéral doit donner
l'approbation
mais attention si on ouvre la
constitution pour le sénat
le kit décor assez propre demande comme
il ya 25 ans je me la soirée à cette
table que si la question du québec est
également nagé dans le sens de ses
revendications traditionnelles
philippe couillard laisse entendre que
la reconnaissance du caractère distinct
de la société québécoise serait comme il
ya un quart de siècle
aucun du débat mais depuis l'échec de
meech le parlement fédéral a reconnu
deux reprises le caractère national du
québec sous jean chrétien 1995
il s'agit d'une reconnaissance réelle et
innover et je crée donc mais de la
gouverne de notre pays puis sur stephen
harper en 2006 que ce job reconnaissent
que les québécoises et les québécois
forment une nation au sein d'un canada
uni
résultat cette reconnaissance s'est
transposée dans les faits dit certains
juristes
moi je prétends que la cour suprême
interprète depuis 25 ans la constitution
en tenant compte du fait que le québec
est une société d'état qu'elle ne le dit
pas comme je viens de vous le dire mais
c'est ce qu'elle fait en pratique
mais la motion du gouvernement harper
sur la nation québécoise a laissé des
traces car elle n'était pas passée comme
une lettre à la poste en particulier
dans certains médias de l'extérieur du
québec où on a eu des tirs
comme c'est la fin du canada tel qu'on
le connaît est-ce que c'est ouvrir cette
résolution leur et le gouvernement qui
doit présenter c'est que le débat a duré
trois jours
un amendement constitutionnel le débat
peut durer jusqu'à trois ans alors en
voyant ça je me suis dit que peut-être
qu'on n'était pas encore plus à dieu
quand même
80 le premier ministre harper qui de
tout temps a bien changé le sénat se
refuse à prendre le risque de rouvrir la
constitution
je pense que la population ne veut pas
de grandes grandes réunions
constitutionnel
cette époque est terminée
d'autant que le québec ne serait pas le
seul à mener c'est demain sur le tapis
en 1990 la question de l'autonomie
gouvernementale des premières nations
porté par le député avait contribué à
faire dérailler l'accord du lac meech
depuis rien de sérieux dans ce dossier
s'il devait y avoir un mouvement vers
cette volonté là de toute évidence la
question autochtone ne devrait pas être
isolé parce que sans son on va
simplement avoir une répétition de tous
les débats finalement autour de l'accord
du lac meech le souvenir de l'échec de
meech et encore si vif dans la classe
politique canadienne que la solution ne
peut être venir d'ailleurs ce qu'ont
peut-être envisager c'est d'enlever sa
des mains des politiciens parce
qu'évidemment aucun politicien ne veut
prendre le risque d'être le demandeur et
de se faire refuser quelque chose
personne ne veut être un perdre